[Music]
alais mohebi is an Afghan refugee who
lives in Freiburg southern Germany he's
been hit hard emotionally by a brutal
murder
the suspect is also a young Afghan
refugee and the mood here is turning
against them
Ali has organized a memorial service for
the student will it help to turn things
around
[Applause]
Alysse spends a lot of time on the phone
he lives in temporary accommodations in
Freiburg Southwest Germany and he feels
like he's under constant suspicion
tempers flared in early December when
the police arrested a young Afghan
refugee he was later charged with the
rape and murder of a 19 year old girl in
October Hawley and the other refugees
here are worried that this crime will
affect their asylum applications
it's the biggest subject among refugees
here everyone's talking about it and
we're all really sad so we decided to
hold a memorial service in Freiburg and
I'd like to organize it this act was
committed by one individual it's
important to me that people understand
this you can't these are all refugees
with the same brush Ali gets in touch
with other refugees via Facebook people
from the refugee home come out to talk
to us we are not allowed to film inside
God will punish him Germans help us they
make such an effort and they're nice to
us I'm happy about that
they know how terrible the situation is
in Afghanistan and that's why they're
helping us the person who murdered this
student did something wrong and we all
have to suffer for it
Freiburg is a peaceful university city
in the mountainous black forest region
it's proud of its liberal atmosphere
Green Party mayor ecological policies
and tolerance toward foreigners that's
why Ali felt welcome here
but this year two young women in the
region were raped and murdered and since
then something has changed in this
cosmopolitan city full of students and
academics
tabloid newspapers printed photos of the
man suspected of raping and murdering a
student they were pictures that he
posted on social networks
flowers marked the scene of the crime 19
year old Maria was cycling home after a
university party she was raped then
murdered next to the drys on River a
passerby found her body the next morning
more details began to emerge it seems
that the young Afghan suspect had
already been charged with a violent
crime three years ago in Greece he was
released early from prison and moved to
Freiburg without the knowledge of German
authorities people here are scared
especially women women in particular had
become more afraid they don't want to
walk alone at night anymore they just
rather take the bus straight home
everyone's talking about it skepticism
is growing people are generalizing
saying all refugees are the same that's
the worst thing we can do bad as against
and it's terrible for the victim and
it's bad for the city tuned it's make
people feel unsafe because you think of
Freiburg is a green alternative place
this kind of thing doesn't seem to fit
murders other crimes and we have to
think about these things you start to
wonder how you deal with a situation
like this because everyone here is open
and welcoming now people are starting to
think differently
especially when evening falls in
Freiburg
Alley is in town with people from the
city's many refugee organizations he's
making preparations for the memorial
service but alleys effort to build
bridges with the Germans is just one
side of the coin people in Freiburg are
still worried about their safety and
some are taking an active stand bar
owner Peter pitch and his colleagues set
up a get home safe initiative to help
women who were out late in the city just
like the victim was his bar is located
right next to the railway he wants to
create a network of cafes and clubs that
offers safe spaces for passers-by even
if they don't want to drink at the
agency there are places you shouldn't go
at night alone and we didn't have that
here before you might have said don't go
into the woods or don't walk alone at
night that was just general advice for
staying safe but when I see what's
happening now it's different but are
people really less safe statistically no
say the police the number of violent
crimes against women has been falling
for years but people's perception of
safety on the city streets at night has
changed of course we feel differently
now about safety in our group of friends
we've all decided that we won't go out
alone anymore only in a group before
especially in summer you'd be out and
about go to a bar or a party somewhere
wander around the city we don't do that
anymore there's a growing sense of fear
throughout Freiburg Ali wants to take a
stand against this for three days he's
been calling on refugees to attend the
memorial
Fryeburg for the murdered student maria
it's the first time he's ever done
anything like this he was deeply shocked
that the suspect was an Afghan national
no I mean by doing this today we're
trying to show that we're not evil
people there are good and bad people
everywhere
maybe the young Afghan who allegedly
committed the crime has problems within
himself the most killer shot see there's
my name informs Romero another I don't
know much about him but not all Afghans
are like him how missing he's chosen
some flowers for the event
here in the center of freiburg ali is
getting nervous
how many people will turn up it's still
early luckily he says a refugee aid
worker is helping him Ali is just 22
years old and he doesn't have much
experience with this kind of thing but
it seems the three days of preparation
have paid off
burnham are avid in body care era when I
heard about what happened I felt really
really sick I felt so sick and went to
the hospital and they gave me some
medicine but I still didn't feel any
better and the stress wouldn't go away
that's why I wanted to do this to come
here with my friends and other people
who share my feelings
it's my calmness with Baker the refugees
are worried about how the attitude
toward them is changing could this
incident in Fryeburg hurt their chances
of staying in Germany almost all asylum
applications from Afghans are rejected
I'd like to thank everyone for coming
you all know why we're gathered here
today we're all deeply saddened by this
terrible tragedy with this event today
we want to show that there are good
Afghans to someone probably a troubled
and stupid individual did something bad
but we're not all like this I wish the
German government could see us as we are
here today
two weeks after the police arrested the
suspect local Afghans held up banners
denouncing the violent crime against the
young student Maria and the people of
Freiburg also took part
but there's a I never thought so many
people would come or so many different
people it's really surprised me in a
positive way the murder in Freiburg has
served only to bolster the populist sand
other opponents of refugees in Germany
after the memorial service more details
came to light about the suspects
criminal past in Greece in 2013 he
attacked a woman and pushed her over an
8 meter high embankment
she suffered serious injuries but
survived
Ali hopes that his involvement will help
to keep Freiburg a tolerant City a place
where refugees from Afghanistan feel
welcome
you